the dichotomy of beauty and violence has
always been a driving theme in The
Witcher series the northern realms
gorgeous vistas are dotted with war-torn
battlefields kindness no matter how
fleeting it may be is often juxtaposed
with savagery and even the warmest of
characters have a cold and calculated
side to them then never-ending tug of
war is ever-present in The Witcher 3
even when it's stripped-down visuals may
obscure some of that beauty
[Music]
everything is here in the Nintendo
switch version The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt
it's two expansions hearts of stone and
blood and wine and all of its DLC the
main game alone offers dozens of superb
quests filled with interesting
characters fantastic twists and
rewarding combat encounters as Kevin Van
Ord said in GameSpot's original review
excellence abounds at every turn in this
open-world role-playing game the same is
mostly true for the Nintendo switch
version as you'd expect the visuals have
been pared down significantly the
textures are muddied the draw distances
are reined in and the resolution has
taken a hit these issues are exacerbated
during docked play while it technically
runs at a higher frame rate and
resolution docked these visual issues
are more noticeable when projected onto
a larger screen handheld mode does a
great job of hiding the blemishes even
though it's running at a lower
resolution the smaller screen gives it a
much crisper look so the poor textures
and popin are less apparent if you do
plan on playing in handheld mode you can
thankfully adjust the size of the HUD to
make things easier to read for returning
players the visual downgrade may require
some getting used to
however focusing solely on The Witcher
3s visuals does this port a disservice
four years later the game is still
massive in scope and seeing the
battle-scarred swamps of velan jagged
peaks of Skellig ax and sprawling
countryside of Tucson on a technically
inferior platform is still a sight to
behold more importantly the grittier
look of the switch port doesn't affect
The Witcher threes core gameplay the
combat and exploration may be smoother
on PC Xbox one X or ps4 pro but I found
performance to be consistent throughout
a wide variety of combat encounters and
locales
[Applause]
after nearly 30 hours I haven't
experienced any significant framerate
dips even the swamps in Velan an area
notorious for causing framerate issues
on ps4 and Xbox one are comparable to
the rest of the experience on switch
according to developers CD Projekt RED
the framerate should range between 24
and 30 frames per second in populated
areas like novigrad the framerate dipped
to the lower end of that range given the
slower pace of The Witcher 3 I never
found these dips to be an issue even in
the heat of combat The Witcher threes
visual prowess may have been a selling
point for some in 2015 but the Nintendo
switch version is a reminder that there
is far more to this adventure than a
pretty picture even today there are few
games that can rival the storytelling
and world building on display here
nothing is as simple as it seems and
every thread you pull on reveals
enticing new details about this world
and its characters the vast web of
decisions and consequences is just as
impressive as it was in 2015 while it
may not be apparent on your first
playthrough your actions both big and
small can have serious repercussions
even if you are trying to do the right
thing what's more impressive is how well
fleshed out each of these paths are and
how they Evan flow through main quests
and side quests while many outcomes are
bittersweet by design none feel
underdeveloped I'm a Witcher are you
wondering about my swords where The
Witcher 3 continues to shine is in its
many deeply human stories all the
political aspects of the main story give
context to the world and its characters
that inhabit it it's the interactions
Geralt has with its denizens that give
weight to the experience at this point
Dad I'll never marry you keep the coin
from Mandy our wedding raise a toast to
my health in
thank you master Witcher there are no
good guys or bad guys there are just
people fighting to find hope in an
oppressive world many quests provoke
questions like would you hurt others for
those you love can even the most vile
men be forgiven and how far can fear
drive someone the superb storytelling
continues in the games - expansions
hearts of stone and blood and wine while
not necessary - the main narrative these
two expansions are thoughtful addendums
- Geralt story blood and wine in
particular is a heartfelt send-off for
the storied series if you're jumping
back into the game and just want to
experience these you can skip right to
them when you load up the game for the
first time
although the Nintendo switch may not be
the best platform to play The Witcher 3
Wild Hunt it's still a fantastic
experience that shouldn't be missed if
you are looking to replay The Witcher 3
and bask in its detail and beauty the
switch port may not quite scratch that
itch however what makes this game
excellent isn't its graphics but the
powerful stories it tells and those are
as vivid as ever on switch
you